allez et venir comme il veut c'est
précieux pour Samuel
la liberté
sa liberté Samuel sait qu'il peut la
perdre à tout moment il a été détenu
durant quelques mois au centre de
surveillance de l'immigration à Laval au
Québec avant la pandémie il a été
relâché quand l'Agence des services
frontaliers du Canada n'est pas parvenu
à le renvoyer dans son pays nous avons
accepté de terre son vrai nom et les
détails qui pourraient l'identifier
parce qu'il craint d'être à nouveau
détenu ça fait peur tu sais pas quand tu
vas sortir et ça dure comme ça tu sais
pas si c'est la semaine prochaine ou un
mois je veux des gens qui ont fait 10
mois
au Canada contrairement à plusieurs
autres pays occidentaux il n'y a pas de
durée limite à la détention liée à
l'immigration pour Samuel l'attente sans
fin était difficile à supporter ça
provoque beaucoup de maladies mentales
j'ai commencé à paniquer Samuel qui a
fui les horreurs de la guerre dans son
pays est encore secoué par sa détention
au Canada c'est beaucoup de tortues
psychologiques beaucoup
décrit lui aussi sa détention par
l'Agence des services frontaliers comme
de la torture psychologique l'homme a
passé 5 ans et 7 mois dans des prisons à
sécurité maximale en Ontario alors que
l'agence essayait en vain de le renvoyer
ensomalie son pays d'origine 5 ans et 7
mois sans jamais savoir quand il allait
sortir
une chemise de la même couleur que
l'uniforme qu'il devait porter comme
prisonnier
de l'immigration ne sont pas accusés
d'un crime pourtant l'Agence des
services frontaliers peut les enfermer
dans l'un de ses centres de
l'immigration ou dans des prisons
provinciales
l'Agence des services frontaliers du
Canada a détenu
800825 migrants en 2019-2020 dont 241
durant plus de 99 jours et 34 durant
plus d'un an la plupart parce que
l'agence craignait qu'il ne se présente
pas une procédure d'immigration comme un
renvoi
libérer il y a 7 ans Monsieur warsam
apporte toujours les traces de son
incarcération il boit après avoir été
battu en prison parce qu'il avait refusé
de céder son beurre d'arachide à déco
détenu mais les blessures psychologiques
sont pire encore
le manque d'une durée limite à la
détention et troublant les détenus
d'immigration ont moins de droits que
les criminels disent-ils
Marco mendescino responsable de l'Agence
des services frontaliers affirme que le
gouvernement cherche toujours à réduire
le recours à la détention du migrants
mais il n'a pas voulu se prononcer sur
l'adoption d'une durée limite à cette
détention ici Brigitte bureau
Radio-Canada
Ottawa